thank you for coming welcome second time
around ready ale and you're right this
is going to be videotaped but you
shouldn't get your hopes up for breaking
it a show business because they can only
see the back of your head but you may
have a very expressive back of your head
in which case somebody may notice you
and give you a call so this lecture on
Einstein generally the best way to clear
a room
other than shouting fire is to say
something about Einstein and then you
have the place to yourself so I'm very
glad that you were not intimidated by
the title and my goal is called no LM
left behind everyone you're all going to
follow this and when you leave this room
you will have a pretty good idea of what
it's all about okay so maybe I should
start by asking if you know how old the
theory of relativity is any idea okay I
heard I heard a century old turns out it
is actually 300 years old
so even though Einstein was the father
of relativity
that's a grandfather who is Galileo and
that's a godfather
who is Newton so they all came before
and did a lot of things and Einstein
actually came much later so that's what
I want to tell you about so you get a
picture of where Einstein belongs so the
way we are going to do this is by the
standard method for teaching the subject
which is to begin with two infinitely
long trains so I'm going to draw you a
finite part of that train so here is one
train and it's a parked in Union Station
in New Haven
this is train one this is train too so
this is the top view of the train now
you get into this train
and all the blinds are drawn you cannot
look outside it is the reason for that
it's not because it's going through
certain parts of New Jersey it's because
we're going to do a scientific
experiment that requires you not to look
outside
so here's let's say you're on this train
there's another train before the shut
the blinds you can look out and see the
other train you can see it's also
standing there then they close the
blinds and you settle down and you
explore the world around you you can do
whatever you want maybe you will pour
yourself a cup of water or you may be
playing pool or if you're physicist
you'll pull your mass and spring system
from your pocket and you will you will
attach immediately attach it to the wall
and pull this mass and see it vibrate so
we all have different ways of exploring
universe this is what I do okay then you
go to sleep and when you are asleep I
tell you that I do one of two things one
is I leave the train along the way this
other is that when you're asleep I give
it a speed of 100 miles per hour and you
wake up and the question is can you tell
whether you have acquired the speed or
not that's the real question you have to
figure it out using the laws of physics
you cannot say I know it's not moving
because it's there's Amtrak
these arguments are sociological they're
not they're not they're not part of
science so the question is will you know
and what Galileo noticed is that you
cannot tell you cannot tell in a moving
train that is moving as long as it's
moving at a constant velocity that's
very important if it's picking up speed
and slowing down and so on you alone but
if it's going at constant velocity
nothing will betray that motion to you
that's it that's the principle we have
all experienced once in a while when the
thing is very smooth our plane is going
very smoothly
you yourself realize that you're not
aware of that motion so the principle of
relativity is a statement that you
cannot tell when it inside a train
whether it's a quite a constant velocity
or not so where is the relative in all
of this I'm going to come to that so if
you open the blind now and you look at
the other train suppose you find the
other train is going like that at 60
miles an hour will you know whether
you're the one who's in motion or the
other train now this has happened to us
quite often when you're parked on the
slope or you put your brakes and if car
is in the slope you see the other car
going forward you think you're slipping
you press the brake harder you get the
impression of movement so the whole
thing is if you look out and you see
this train going that way
can you tell the answer is you can tell
that is portion between the two of you
that is the fact but you cannot really
say for sure you are the one who has
started off when you were sleeping and
maybe you did nothing the other train
got into motion in the opposite
direction so velocity between two such
people is relative in the sense that we
can perceive it but we cannot be sure
who is actually moving or whether
there's any real sense in which one of
us really is moving in fact if these two
trains were in outer space you just
wouldn't know now if you look at the
other side let's say you open the window
here and look you see a lot of cows and
Street cows are running at 60 miles an
hour
now the question is what do you think is
happening is it the cow service is the
train so I know what you're going to say
you're going to say it's got to be the
cows but you realize theoretically
Amtrak trains can move so that's the
possibility you're not willing to admit
that even though it's very remote so you
keep thinking it's the cows but it could
be it could be possible that's the cows
are not moving it's the train so once
again there is no way to resolve the
difference so the summary of what I
mentioned here is that constant velocity
doesn't do anything that you can measure
if you're inside you cannot figure out
that's being given to you that's not
true for non-uniform motion that's not
true for accelerated motion for example
if the engine driver slams the brake you
know you're going to ram into the seat
in front of you now if you if the blinds
fly open you look at the other train
it'll be decelerating the opposite
direction can you say nothing is
happening to me you're the one who's
accelerating the other way well you
cannot say that first of all you've lost
all your teeth cannot say anything can
you scribble a note and say I'm not
moving you're moving well he will say if
if that's the case how come you have no
T because accelerated motion namely the
slamming of the brake produces effects
that you feel you cannot pass the buck
to the other person and say you're
moving the office away or if you're an
astronaut and your rocket is taking off
you are the one who feels all the
g-forces you cannot argue that the rest
of the planet is going the opposite way
because they seem to be doing fine so
here is the main thing if you're inside
a closed strain and the Train axle rates
at decelerates or goes on a curve you
can tell if it's going at constant
velocity you really cannot tell that's
it that's what Galileo said that's
called Galileo's principle of relativity
and it's more than 300 years old so then
the next person who comes in not much
later is Newton so what did Newton do
well Newton actually not only
agreed with what Galileo said he
actually explained why it is true so I'm
going to tell you how in Newton's point
of view you can actually understand what
we all are aware of well Newton as you
know wrote down three laws of physics
I'm going to only talk about the first
law the second law says something is
equal to something else but I'm told in
alumni reunions I should not write any
equations but that every equation cost
the development office $600,000
so no equations so I'll just take the
first law okay the first law is a lot as
a rambling sentence it's quite safe it
says the following it's a law of inertia
kwatak the law of inertia if there are
no forces acting on a body it will
either stay at rest if it started at
rest or if it had an initial velocity
will keep maintaining the initial
velocity unless it's acted upon by a
force that's the first law basically the
first law says the velocity of an object
will not change unless a force acts on
it now we are all familiar with the
first law I mean here it is I take this
cup here and I put it there
no force is acting on it it stays where
it is so the law of inertia works for me
if it works for me I'm called an
inertial observer inertial observer is
one for whom Newton's laws work so this
works now the second part of the first
law that if something has a constant
velocity it will keep on doing it
forever it's hard to visualize in daily
life you give a push to something it
goes a few feet and stops you don't it's
hard to believe that it'll go on forever
for free but we know that if you reduce
the friction more and more or you went
on ice and you give it a shop it keeps
moving for a long time before it stops
and an idealization is that if the ice
is completely frictionless whatever you
set in motion will move forever so
that's harder to visualize in daily life
but Galili have the imagination to
realize that if you
use the friction that would happen
nowadays in outer space you can easily
verify that if you throw something it
will just keep going at that speed
without anybody pushing it so that's the
law of Newton and I want to just show
you the following if Newton's law works
for me when I'm in the platform let's
say this is the station then it will
continue to work even when the Train is
set into motion in other words if
newton's laws work before the Train
moved it will continue to work even when
the Train has a constant speed that's
what I want to explain that will show
you that Newton's laws are valid in the
moving train as they are on the static
train and when is when we say the world
looks the same what we really mean is
the laws of mechanics looks the same
because lots of mechanics tell you
everything that you can see in the
mechanical world is explained by them so
how do I know that the first law will
work in a moving train that's what I
want to explain to you so let me draw a
side picture of the train here is a
train there is a table here which is
frictionless and that is a person
sitting here okay my drawings a constant
source of amusement for my class so this
is a person sitting on a chair and this
is a mug of beer on a which this
inebriated person has put on a
frictionless table
now the train is moving at 60 miles per
hour
now I'm looking at the whole thing from
the ground so I see the whole thing
going by everything on the train is
going at 60 miles an hour
beer the person everything now what will
the person in the train think I argue as
follows the beer mug starts at 60 miles
per hour there are no forces on it
because there's no friction nothing so
it'll keep going at 60 miles an hour the
Train I've been assured is going at a
constant speed of 60 therefore the mug
and the person are all going at the same
speed so the distance between them will
not change that's what I predict he will
see and indeed he will find the mug
stays where it is that's how I can show
that the law of inertia will work on the
train because it works for me and I can
translate what I see into what he will
see now imagine that the person gives
the the beer mug a shove so he starts
going away from him at the speed of 10
miles per hour
it starts out that way what will happen
next I know what will happen next
because I am still on the ground I am
allowed to use Newton's laws and I say
this mug is going at 70 miles per hour
that's the 10 plus a 60 of the Train and
this guy is still going at 60 so the
difference in speed between them is 10
and that difference cannot change that
means according to the person of the
Train this mug will maintain its speed
of 10 so I predict the person in the
train will find the Newton's first law
of inertia to be valid basically the
idea is the person in the Train and I
don't see everything the same way we
disagree on where anything is I think
the mug is going towards Boston he
thinks the mug is in front of him I
think the mug is are going at 60 miles
per hour he thinks it's at rest but the
differences are only with respect to
velocity not with respect to
acceleration the fact that the mug speed
is not changing is true for me and it's
true for him and that's all the first
law of inertia say speed will not change
without a good reason
imagine now that suddenly the Train
picks up speed so start going from sixty
towards 70 miles per hour
what will the person in the Train see
well I don't have the person in the
Train is allowed to use Newton's law or
not but I'm still allowed to do it
because I haven't done anything I am
still on the platform so I argue as
follows
this mug is still going at 60 this
person is starting to move at 70 I know
what will happen the 70 will gain on the
60 and the two will soon meet how will
it look like in the Train the person in
the Train it would look like the mug is
sliding backwards towards him that's
what happens in a plane you didn't take
off if you leave something on the tray
in front of you it slides towards you
towards the back in fact everything the
plane that's not nailed down goes to the
back of the plane during takeoff that's
why all the physicists sit at the last
row collecting of whatever stuff
okay so okay you have any question you
can ask me now any questions okay so
everything on the train will accelerate
to the back of the Train for no apparent
reason
that means the world will not look
Newtonian to the person of the Train
that's so when he wakes up he will know
the train is accelerating because when
you accelerate nothing stays where it is
things go back you got to be very
careful when you use the law you can say
I went to Grand Central Station
I left my ipod there and I came back it
was gone
what about the law of inertia well I
guarantee you that the laws that were
broken have nothing to do with Newton so
some some unseen hand has come and taken
the iPod that's always an explanation
but in an accelerating train everything
will accelerate backwards that's the
reason why accelerated motion can have
effects you can detect but uniform
motion will leave no trace you will
never know that's it that's all that is
right up to the time of Newton so
gallantly observed that if you want
Newton explained that he said these are
my loss of motion and my loss of motion
are such that if they work for me on the
ground they work for me on the train as
long as the Train is going at constant
velocity all right so I have not said
anything about one of the key
ingredients in this theory which has not
entered the picture yet you know what I
have in mind what do you think of
anything of relativity what's the first
thing that comes to your mind right okay
our case you think about the velocity of
light the velocity of light is not
entered picture and now it's going to
enter so the velocity of light is
something that is occupied minds for
many years
alfred lee newman who you might know
he said this much I know about the
velocity of light it comes here too
early in the morning after that every
other quotation is going to be trivial
but I'll tell you what other people had
to say Galileo for one was very eager to
find out if the velocity of light is
finite or infinite namely does it take
any time at all for the light signal to
go from here to there or does it happen
at once so he did that by taking one of
his friends and he went on top of one
mountain and his friend went on top of
another mountain so this is Galileo is
the friend and they both had these
lanterns which can be covered so here's
the deal he made with his friend he said
I would suddenly open my cover to my
lantern so emit a flash of light the
minute you see it the light signal is
going to you mean it you see it you open
the thing in your Lantern
I'll see that flash of light come here
so I look at how long it takes for a
round-trip then i'll divide the distance
I'll divide by divide the distance by
the time and I will get a speed that was
Galilee as planned now we don't know
what method he used to measure time one
theories are used to water clock other
words he used this pulse which is a
reasonably good way to measure for
example the pendulum the church very was
spraying Galilee or notice that the
period of the pendulum doesn't depend on
how big it the oscillations are that he
did with his pulse so I don't know how
he measured it so he got a speed but you
know that that was not the right speed
because what he was really measuring is
just the time it takes to react and how
do you know that's what's happening how
do you tell that you're just measuring
your reaction time how will you know
that's the case you think of how to
realize your own mistake for me or yeah
that's right
that's very true you can sit on the same
mountain or go to nearby mountain or a
further away amount and you keep getting
the same time you realize it's not the
time of light travel you measuring but
delay to respond so Galileo figured that
it's very fast he gave some multiple of
the speed of some and but he didn't say
I don't remember what it was
what he said is at least that fast the
real breakthrough came and an astronomer
called Romer found a way to find the
velocity of light that's a very
ingenious method so I'm going to give
you a bare-bones version of it it's got
you can put bells and whistles on it but
the idea is still the same so here is
the Sun and let's say here is the earth
going on its orbit and here is Jupiter
going on its orbit and this is Jupiter
and at the time when I want to do this
thing
Jupiter is here Earth is here and
there's a moon of Jupiter called IO
which is going round and round let's say
it goes around exactly every hour so
every time the moon comes in front of
Jupiter I see it and I make a notation I
say I saw the Jupiter as a function of
time I draw a blip then one hour later I
should get a second blip and at two
hours I should get a third blip and so
on because all these motions are
completely periodic is like a clock but
what you find is that the second blip
doesn't arrive on time but comes a
little later third one comes even later
and the reason is that the earth is
moving away from Jupiter so the delay
keeps on accumulating till six months
later it's quite a bit
several minutes compared to when the
pulse is supposed to come 300 the pulse
let us say comes ten minutes after it's
supposed to come that 10 minutes is then
the extra time it takes light to go
across the orbit of the earth around the
Sun and people have pretty good idea
it's like hundred million miles and then
you take the extra time and you divide
it and you get a speed and he got a
pretty good answer the answer he got was
like two hundred thousand kilometers per
second and the correct answer nowadays
we know it's like three hundred thousand
kilometers per second but it is a
remarkable achievement and you need
something of cosmological proportions
before you can find the velocity of
light
you do anything in the laboratory things
happen so quickly later on people found
a way to measure it in the lab but this
is the first astronomical measurement
all right so light was then shown to
have a finite velocity of propagation
and the velocity was improved and by the
time I come to the next part of the
story
people knew pretty much the answer is
300,000 kilometers per second all right
so then there is a new development about
light people don't know what light is
they don't know what's going on they
just know it travels at the speed then a
person called young did an experiment
which shows that light is actually a
wave I should tell you what we mean by
that statement what does it mean to say
something is a wave waves a one very
important property first of all we all
know what waves are in water you can
have waves the thing is going up and
down up and down in relation to some
undisturbed level of water waves have
the property that they can interfere and
that means the following imagine that
this is your estate and there is a beach
here and you park your yacht
this is towed to give this to the Yale
alumni your yacht is part I don't do
this in the classroom because they don't
know what I'm talking about but you guys
you all have one right okay so you put
your yard here and the waves are coming
to block them you put a barricade so
your yard is very tranquil suddenly
there is a breach and these waves will
come from this opening now radiate out
and they will come to your board and the
board will shake suppose you want to
avoid that there are two solutions one
is to find a way to block this but if
all you have is say a sledgehammer you
can still make progress because you can
go and you can make a second breach here
now that looks like bad news because now
stuff is going to come from here too but
you can arrange it so that when this guy
and this guy
meet they cancel each other because you
see takes a little longer to go from
here to there compared to that one so
you got the crest and a trough and a
crest and a trough you can arrange it so
that when a crest from here comes a
trough from there comes so one is
telling the water go up are they selling
the water to go down so it doesn't do
anything little later this one says go
down and that one says go up and doesn't
do anything so you can find it you can
arrange it so that you don't have any
activity here that's called interference
so two waves can cancel and if instead
of water waves if this was light and you
had a source of light here and a dark
screen with two holes in it and you put
another screen where behind you look at
it you will find patterns of dark and
bright and dark and bright dark were the
two camps of cancel and bright where the
two add up that's called interference
and he showed that when you do it with
light you get interference so it's a way
but you don't know what it is that's
waving see sound is a wave but I know
exactly what's moving when I talk to you
when my diaphragm pushes in and out it
changes the air pressure and the add
pressure propagates to you and it goes
to your ear then the eardrum starts to
move after that I don't know that's the
biology department some wires come and
pick it up and stop goes to your brain
okay that's where we check out at the
eardrum
but I know that's how it travels so
that's the propagation of sound in a
violin string also when you pluck the
string we know the deviation from
horizontal that blip is what travels
back and forth for light no one knew
what it was you know it's a way we know
it's got a wavelength that we can
measure but what is it that's really
shaking and what's the medium in which
all this is happening that was not known
so Maxwell this is the this last
character before Einstein was studying
electromagnetism is not interested in
light studying electricity and magnetism
electricity is quite familiar right it's
when you rub your feet on the carpet and
you touch the doorknob you get a spark
this electricity magnetism has been
known to people from ancient Greeks when
parents noticed that kids were sticking
stuff on the refrigerator using some
little black rocks so from that time
magnetism has been studied but we can
say you have a magnetic field if the
compass needle will do anything then
there's a magnetic field there so what
what max was studying is how this
electric and magnetic fields travel in
space and he found out they travel like
waves and you calculated the speed of
the waves and you put the numbers in and
you get a speed which is universally
oops I will not write anything I just
write here 3 times 10 to the 8 meters
per second so he got that speed that was
a real shock that electromagnetic waves
travel at exactly the speed as the speed
of light so they said electromagnetism
must be light now you got to be very
careful just because you're traveling
for example if I'm running next to a
buffalo at the same speed doesn't mean I
can conclude I'm a buffalo right we just
have the same speed so the fact that
electromagnetic waves are the same speed
as light doesn't mean it's like well
they said that's what it is and they
were right but later on we know the
gravity waves also travel at the speed
of light but they are not light but at
that time they were quite right so light
was in fact electromagnetic waves and
the question is
these waves moving in they said let's
give it a name we'll call it the ether
there's something called ether and
ethers everywhere it's even between here
and the distant stars we know it's there
because we can see the Stars
if there is no ether between us and the
Stars the light cannot travel without
the medium so ethers everywhere okay
then the speed of light is calculated to
be this number is always in the medium
in which it travels for example the
speed of sound is 700 and
something-something miles per hour with
respect to the air if I travel now with
respect to that air in the direction of
the sound the speed will change for me
the speed of sound will be reduced in
fact you can you mention will go even
faster than some if you could fly in the
Concord that's what it does it goes even
faster than some so the speed of sound
is the number that's given with respect
to the air in which it is traveling the
speed of light must be the speed with
respect the medium in which light is
traveling this mysterious ether so if I
go and measure the speed of sound
today in my lab I would generally not
expect to get that number because in all
probability my lab is moving relative to
this mysterious eat there are some speed
that difference must show up in the
speed of light but when you measure it
you get exactly the answer as if you
were at rest
respect the medium then you say okay you
know what maybe today my lab at this
instant is at rest but wait 12 hours a
few more hours since the earth is
spinning one instant you're moving like
this twenty twelve hours later you're
moving like that you cannot be addressed
the whole time also you're going around
the Sun you cannot be addressed the
whole time and yet no matter when you
measure the speed of light you get the
same answer daytime nighttime anytime of
the year moving whichever way you like
you get the same answer and one simple
explanation was maybe the earth is
carrying the either with it
for example the atmosphere we are
breathing we don't leave it behind us
the earth moves
we carry the atmosphere with us or when
you go in a plane if you talk to
somebody across the other end of the
plane you don't have to worry about the
fact the whole thing is moving because
the air is being carried by the plane
you don't have to worry about it
so they said maybe
that's what's happening maybe the ether
is carried by the earth but one can show
from celestial experiments looking at
stars that you cannot take it with you
cannot take the ether with you then you
have a real problem here is this thing
travelling in some mysterious medium no
matter who is looking at it it has the
same speed you realize that's very
strange how can something have the same
speed for everybody
someone standing someone moving someone
moving the opposite way they all get the
same speed so people didn't know what to
make of it till Einstein came and said I
know what's going on I know why light is
behaving this way forget about ether
there is no medium collie that we don't
need it I'm just going to postulate that
the speed of light is same for everybody
no matter how they're moving now you
might think this guy is famous for
saying that I mean he doesn't explain
anything
he just says it's the way it is because
it's the way it is I'm going to
postulate it so that's if that's all he
had done it would not be the whole story
he explained why the speed of light is
the way this he said if I go to the
strain that Galileo talked about and I
wake up I do all experiments with water
and masses and springs and they all look
exactly the same as before but suppose I
sink the center light pulse and measured
its speed if the speed of light
dependent on the speed of the train I
will get a different answer when I wake
up and from that difference I can deduce
the fact that I'm moving that means the
loss of mechanics conspired to hide my
motion but not the loss of light loss of
optics he said I don't buy that I don't
believe that some laws of nature remain
the same in a moving train and other
laws vary so the speed of light behaves
the way it does because it's part of a
big conspiracy to hide your velocity as
long as it's uniform that's why light
behaves the way it does it have to if it
had behaved any other way
person on a moving train can detect her
speed without looking outside that means
there's at least one thing that is
different in the moving train maybe
mechanics it's the same optics is
different he said I don't buy that
everything
is got to be the same it was an act of
faith really even though it's not a very
religious person most scientists may be
religious may not be religious but they
all physicists certainly have a belief
in the order of natural phenomena we
believe you are playing against a
reasonable opponent that the puzzles
have reasonable and clever answers and
whoever designed the system certainly
will make sure that the laws of science
behave uniformly that everything is same
on the train
not just mechanics not the first 10
chapters of my book but the whole book
so he said that now you can say is that
all he did no because in saying the
speed of light is a constant he then set
himself up for a lot of consequences
which are very bizarre and that's what
I'm going to talk about now because you
should think about what it means to say
the speed of something is a constant so
imagine you're standing on the ground
and there is a car and it's speeding by
at some 60 mph you clock it is going at
60 now suppose you get into another car
and you travel in the same direction at
40 mph you expect the speed of this to
be 20 everybody agrees you got to
subtract your 40 from that 60 that's how
velocity is hand if you had a velocity
of 60 from the ground and you go at 40
to the right you subtract your 40 and
you get 20 but what I'm telling you is
if this had not been a car but a light
pulse
you know signal of light this traveling
if it had a speed C on the ground it has
the same speed C even seen by a moving
car moving in the same direction in fact
even if this car is going at half the
speed of light it would still appear to
travel at the full speed to that person
that is what Einstein says is happening
but you realize that means big trouble
right it's not the way things behave so
let me make it very very clear here is a
light signal going at speed C as seen by
the ground I am going at a speed 3/4 of
C what do I what does he think I should
get
he thinks I should get 1/4 C as the
measures be but I get C so that the
velocity I get is much bigger than what
he expects so what how do you explain
that so you say look I thought you will
get 1/4 of C but you're getting C so
something is wrong with the way you're
doing your measurement how do you
measure it speed you see how far it goes
by putting some meter sticks one against
each other then you see how long it
takes with your clock you divide
distance over time and in that
calculation some of you are getting four
times the answer now there are two ways
in which it can happen one way is that
your clocks are not running at the same
rate as before when we were both
standing relative to each other at rest
the minute you went on the strain some
of your clocks have slowed down suppose
they're running at 1/4 the normal speed
and that means when light has gone for 4
seconds you think it's gone for only 1
second so you divide by 1 instead of 4
that's why you got this 4 times the
answer another option is the meter
sticks which we bought from the same
store which used to agree before you got
on your train your meter sticks of
shrunk they're shrunk to 1/4 their size
so that when light is gone only 4 yard
do you think is gone 16 yards so you
knew you either inflate the numerator or
reduce the denominator in the velocity
calculation to get this or maybe you're
doing both maybe both things are
happening but something has to happen so
you have to abandon your notion that
meter sticks and clocks run at the same
rate in a moving train as in a static
train and then he went on and calculated
the amount by which these two things
happen
that's a calculation I won't perform but
I do want to tell you some of the
interesting consequences then I will
stop talking then we we can explore the
consequences the first consequence is
that events which are simultaneous for
me may not be simultaneous for you so
here's an example you can give so
imagine a pair of twins okay one is born
in LA one is born in New York did you
listen to what I said this one is
so when I when I mention this to my
class they pointed out that no ordinary
mother could've given this is a mother
from the yo mama jokes
she is so big she can give birth to kids
coast-to-coast
alright so anyway let's forget the kids
let's say there is some other event that
takes place simultaneously according to
me then the claim is that if you go on a
rocket ship or any other state of motion
you will think they're not simultaneous
that is really interesting right because
we have a notion that when things two
things happen at the same time say in LA
in New York that's the real meaning in
which they happen at the same time we're
not fooled by the fact the time
difference of three hours we know there
is a sense in which there really did
happen at the same time we think that's
an absolute statement but the point is
that if the whole events are seen by a
moving observer there will not be at the
same time and this is how Einstein
explained it so he said let me take this
train we just at rest and I want to make
two things happen are the two ends of
the train at the same time maybe two
explosions so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take two mirrors placed
like that at some angle I'm going to
send a light signal from here it'll
split one will go to the left and one
will go to the right and since it I'm
right in the middle of the train they
will go and hit the two ends and let's
say the trigger two explosions those
explosions happen at the same time I
couldn't have done it more carefully but
now imagine that the train that I am in
is actually moving related with the
platform and you are seeing it from the
platform to you this is what's happening
let's see what you will say is happening
the light signal left here this signal
is going to the right at the speed C the
speed of light is the same but this end
of the train is moving away from their
signal where at this side of the train
is rushing to meet the signal it's very
clear this end will hit first and a
little later the light will hit that end
so you will agree that to the person on
the ground the two events would not be
simultaneous
now here is where people sometimes ask
why do you use this light signal why not
send two pigeons produce two pigeons and
see what they do I'll just shout hey do
that and the two guys the two into the
train do what you said the reason you
don't do any of those is we don't know
anything about the behavior of sound in
this new relativistic physics we don't
know about you can send to Federal
Express guys will they get that at the
same time we don't know because we don't
how they behave but one thing we do know
is by postulate the velocity of light is
a constant regardless of the source
regardless of the observer that's why I
can say with confidence that even though
the signal is emitted in the train the
right signal and left signal both travel
at the same speed c1 towards it and
that's running away from it one - at the
end that's rushing to meet it
consequently they won't be simultaneous
now it turns out that this lack of
simultaneity is really there and you
just cannot say who is right and who is
wrong you just can say I made it as
simultaneous as I could the best of my
ability but you don't have to agree it's
a very interesting case what people
really can disagree on what the
simultaneous and what's not it depends
on the observer so that's the immediate
consequence you can see where it came
from you got to do more work if you want
to know how much is the time difference
for that you got to do calculation but
the fact that they won't occur at the
same time you can see immediately now
this also means that two events with a
simultaneous for one person can occur in
different sequences even a can occur
before B and I can find a guy for whom B
occurred before a now if your Einsteins
you should again get worried in fact the
greatest thing but I understand which
you admire once you start practicing any
kind of Sciences not only that he was
very clever but he was very gutsy
because once you invent something new
and the mathematics takes you in all
kinds of directions you have no choice
you're wedded to that formalism and you
got to defend all the consequences of
your theory so here's the consequence a
and B are two events which are
simultaneous for me but not simultaneous
for you
you can also show that if a occurred
after B for me then B cannot occur after
a for someone else that can lead to a
lot of paradoxes so event a is my father
is born even B is I am born okay now
there's another observer for whom I am
born but my father is not born yet you
realize that causes a lot of problems
right the nurse says what shall we name
this kid I don't know his father is not
born yet no you don't want that to
happen so there are certain events where
one event is causally connected to a
second event but a is the cause of B in
this case my father is the reason I am
here
the theory should not I love the order
of those events to be exchanged that
other events where it could not have
been the cause of B that's defined in
relativity as such that there is no time
for a light signal to go from event a to
even B then no way a can influence be in
the in that case you can find another
person for whom the ordered is reversed
so the order of events is not it in some
sense is absolute if a is the cause of B
or could have been the concept B theory
doesn't allow me to exchange their order
but if they are not causally connected
you can find people who completely
disagree on when something happened okay
so that's the second thing involving
time and here's another thing involving
time that's very interesting
remember I said maybe a moving clock
slows down let's see how that can happen
now if you take the clock that I am
wearing
there's no way we can show that because
I have no idea what's in it open it
nothing is moving nowadays we don't have
clocks work and Einstein didn't know how
clocks work either
but he devised or at least to teach it
we devised a very simple clock where we
can all understand why a moving clock
slows down this clock is simplicity
itself you got two mirrors and you have
a source of light that emits a blip it
goes to the top mirror and bounces back
and goes back and forth and every time
it makes a round-trip it hits a detector
and it goes click okay
that's my clock the round trip is L plus
another L view / speed of light you get
the time that's the time period of my
clock so I have a clock like that and
you have a clock like that and your
clock and mine are identical we bought
them at the same store but now you go on
your train you hold your clock and I
look at your clock here is what I find
your clock is doing this because you are
moving according to me so when the light
was emitted at the bottom you were here
a little later you were there when
they'd hit the top then you were here
and then you were there in other words
an up-and-down motion in the train looks
like a zigzag motion from the ground we
can all understand that but it's the
exact path we all know is longer than
straight up and down it's a very simple
calculation to see how much longer and
that this involves Pythagoras theorem
namely comparing the hypotenuse to the
vertical side and you can get the time
difference so I can tell you how much
you will be slow but here is the paradox
paradoxes you are entitled to say you
are not moving at all because the loss
of mechanics that everything is same for
you as for me in fact according to you
my clock is going that way is exactly
opposite way so you understand how if
you and I have two clocks my clock is up
and down your zigzag for me and
according to you the picture is just
reversed so each person is able to argue
the other person's clock is running slow
because it's not taking the shortest
path so going on a zigzag but this leads
to a paradox what if these two guys meet
when they meet one day whose clock will
really be behind because each seems to
have a solid case so that is the twin
paradox the twin paradox is the
following you have this same twins one
is now in Houston or in Florida the
other gets into rocket goes on an orbit
around the Earth 500 times and they come
back now the person in the ground says
hey you've been moving and therefore
your clock is slow therefore when I
compared your clock to my clock your
clock should have take to er seconds
then
but what if the person the rocket says
the same thing you can say I'm not
moving you're moving so you should be in
fact forget clocks the human body is a
clock I am a clock if you watch me
patiently in a few years the rest of my
head will fall down my teeth will fall
down you can measure time in decades by
watching human beings if you cannot wait
you can watch the cells how they grow
and die in the replicate the human body
is a clock therefore the human body's
aging should also slow down in a moving
plane so the twin paradox is more
dramatically illustrated by saying the
following suppose the twin on the earth
waited 10 years for the journey to end
and the twin on the rocket by the time
is aged only five years so when they
meet the rocket wind should be younger
than the one who didn't go on the trip
but what if the rocket Quinn says I
never went anywhere you went somewhere
you should be younger the person is when
they meet who will be right you have to
answer that if you're I understand you
have to provide a definite answer
because when you do the experiment you
can get only one answer so the answer
that Einstein gave is that the person
who went on the rocket will be younger
now why is that why is it that they both
cannot make the same claim the answer is
that I am on the earth I never went
anywhere Newton lost valid for me the
whole time you got into this rocket when
for a brief period you were accelerating
you knew that Newton's laws didn't work
in your frame if you accelerate it too
much you are going to die not me then
your accelerated picked up speed then
you can go to uniform speed then you
slowed down turned around picked up
speed and came back slowed down and
stopped so you have done a lot of
acceleration therefore you are the
person who cannot ever claim to be equal
to me so the answer to the twin
paradoxes is not really paradox the
twins are not equal in the claim one had
accelerated motion in the other dude so
these two clocks which are going in
opposite direction can never be compared
unless one of them stops moving and goes
to the other one whoever stops and turns
around and goes back that clock is moved
that clock would be behind the other
clock so this is the manner in which the
twin paradox which is
and people now find that even though
human beings cannot be kept alive much
longer by traveling elementary particles
can be lot of particles produced in
Geneva for example they're not supposed
to live very long but if they go at very
high velocities their internal clock
slows down and they live much much
longer than you expect so that is the
behavior of time in this theory the
behavior of length is more complicated
so I don't want to explain that but the
claim is that whenever a broad starts
moving relative to you you would think
it's shorter than it is everything
that's moving will appear short to you
and according to that person everything
you have will appear short to that
person you got to make sure there are no
paradoxes there these are other things
one can study if one wants to but I
didn't want to do all of that so let me
just say the point I want you to carry
is that I'm going to stop so you're at
least 10 minutes to question me the
point was the principle of relativity
says that when you get into a train
which is going at a constant speed there
is nothing that will betray that
constant speed to you it makes no
difference it was true for mechanics and
in the end is also true for light but if
it's true for light it led to a very
strange requirement that the speed of
light be the same for all observers and
that is very contradictory to popular
intuition by the speed of something
depends on how fast you're moving so
Einstein said well I will not let light
change its speed I will let our
measurement of time and space change
suitably to accommodate the constant
velocity of light that's what led to the
change in the notion of simultaneity how
long it takes for a clock to tick how
long is any object it all depends on how
you measure it so space and time got
revolutionized so that in the end the
speed of light comes out to be the same
that's the first part of relativity
equal MC square is not anywhere near
this in fact it's not a central result
in this theory it is great
phenomenological consequence but you can
see there is no reference to that right
now and it's not that easy to explain as
to what I was able to explain to you so
it's really a footnote where
not for the great consequences it has as
a logical structure that comes somewhere
else what I mentioned to you is the
heart of the special theory a few years
after that Einstein generalized his
theory to the general theory of
relativity in which he said I don't even
like the fact that an accelerated person
has to admit he is accelerating I want
him to also talk his way out of
acceleration you can see how can that be
when you are an accelerated train all
kinds of stuff starts rushing to the
back of your train how can you talk your
way out of it and here is how you can do
that here is my train and if I'm
accelerating you agree nothing anything
that's not nailed down goes to the back
of the Train falls Edison drape to the
back of the Train here is what I can say
is happening my train is not moving at
all but when I was sleeping you went and
put a huge fat planet behind my train
which is pulling everything I leave here
towards that so you cannot tell if you
are in the gravitational field of a
planet or whether you are accelerating
the opposite way so that's how gravity
enters the theory so Einstein's general
theory is really a theory of gravitation
see gravity has a remarkable fact that
everything falls at the same rate that's
a remarkable property of gravitation
whatever you drop falls at the same rate
therefore you can imagine being in outer
space no gravity but your lab is
accelerating upwards at 9.8 meters per
second there also everything you drop
will go to the floor at 9.8 basically
the objects are not going the floor is
rushing to meet them but you cannot tell
the difference so that's how the
gravitation theory was deduced by
Einstein a few years later that is
viewed by one and all as the most
imaginative leap made by pure thought
because that was done not because of any
experiment but by sense of
dissatisfaction with the special theory
that it made people in uniform motion
equal but he wanted to make everybody
equal and then in the quest for that he
found this great theory all right so I
will stop now and answer questions thank
you
okay see a hand in the back yes remember
10 miles an hour is the speed you give
it a speed of 10 miles an hour and if
you are going that means from the ground
the the beer will be going at 70 you
will be going at 60 if you pick up speed
that's acceleration if you go from 60 to
70 if you gain speed then you know you
will catch up with the mug but from the
train point if you look like the mug
came back to meet you okay yes the in
the general theory there is no paradox
at all so you can also solve it but in
other words you can say this involves
accelerated motion so we won't answer it
if you want you can use a general theory
to actually show very clearly why one
person will be slower than the other one
yes
yes but it won't be simultaneous for a
guy on the train yes you can arrange it
so that the person on the ground is
satisfied to their simultaneous what you
won't be in the Train so if you do it so
simultaneous for you it would not be
simultaneous on the ground but you're
quite right you can move the mirror
closer to the other type front end of
the train so it's simultaneous for a
person on the ground but then it's not
simultaneous for you so it is still true
that you could not agree on what
simultaneous yes yeah you gotta be
careful the only speed that is same for
everybody is the speed of light okay a
train going at 1/4 the speed of light
will not like you appear to have that
speed for everybody some people can say
it's less than 1/4 some people can't is
more than 1/4 so it's not that any
formula that has a scene it doesn't
change it's got to be really at speed
speed of C so the velocity of light is
the only speed that is same for all
people
half the velocity of light is not the
same for all people oh one here and then
one there yes yes
well a gravity wave is so maybe one way
one way to think about gravity waves is
that we are supposed to be in a in a
space-time in which there is something
called a curvature of space-time so that
the distance between points can be
stretched or contracted it's like saying
maybe
here's your on a rubber sheet and you
mark some dots okay and the dots are
spaced uniformly so of course the ripple
goes past the rubber sheet you realize
that when the ripple goes past you some
points will move further away and some
will be closer so that's a real wave on
a real diaphragm producing the distance
it returns out in free space if you take
two points which you think are a meter
apart when a gravity wave goes past it's
a change in the underlying fabric of
space-time so that for that short time
they will seem to be the closer out
further so gravity wave is one in which
the actual distance between points
changes when the wave goes fast
yeah if they act they accelerate it like
yes your question is is only the
accelerated portion that you think will
make a difference that what you're
saying no it will actually also remember
how long you went on a straight line
also yes
whether okay so the Doppler effect is
the phenomenon that when waves are
emitted towards you so a crest comes in
a trough comes in a crest comes you time
them that's the frequency of sound but
if as I talk to you I also walk towards
you which I can do after some practice
then you will find out that the crest
appeared to come to you a lot quicker
because I emit a crest then I move and
emit the next one so they're squashed
that's the Doppler shift and that is
nothing to do with relativity we can
understand that in Newtonian mechanics
but in relativistic mechanics that's the
added fact that when I'm moving my clock
is different from your clock that's
called the transverse a Doppler effect
and you can one way to see that I mean
that's an extra contribution to Doppler
effect but you can best see it when you
are going around another person when you
go around another person you're not
emitting waves towards them or away from
him and yet there will be a shift that's
because when you're moving in a circle
your clocks are different from mine and
your frequency will be different from my
you think you're singing at some
frequency I will hear it at a different
frequency
but with light is a constant yeah the
emitter is moving toward you talk about
the redshift yeah the expanding right
yeah that shift is really that really
can be understood as a classical
Newtonian shift if a galaxy is receding
from you the light adem it's shifted
towards the red because the crests are
further apart than they normally would
be so the color looks redder than the
actual color yeah okay first I gotta
tell you I don't know what a warp is
okay because we don't know okay what
point is speed of light okay speed of
light as far as I understand definitely
not possible for any material object the
only thing the traveling speed of light
is light
that's what roosevelt said only thing
traveling at the speed of light is light
itself nothing
fund me ah here's a question if you can
go faster than light a lot of things
will happen one of them will be that you
will see the effect appear before the
cause and that will lead to logical
contradiction that's one of the
consequences so that you will find that
if I if I fire a bullet can you move
away a little bit yes like and it hits
that door okay
hits him then this is the cause that's
the effect you will find another
observer if you go faster than light
that he got shot and I've not even
pulled out my gun meanwhile somebody
grabs my gun that's poor guy has been
shot for no reason
ok-hee he is on a risky mission here
right okay any other things oh yes yeah
okay now you cannot go at the speed of
light but imagine you are going at point
nine nine nine nine nine times the speed
of light everything will be the same the
minute you turn on the light bulb light
will spread out and illuminate the room
as if you were not moving you will not
know in fact here's a point you somehow
say I am going at that speed right with
respect to whom how do you know you're
going at the speed because there's no
it's always relative to somebody else
you're going at that speed
normally you may mean with respect to
mother earth but that is an arbitrary
human interest right normally the speed
of some system is defined only relative
to other systems in the claim is that
you cannot deduce any intrinsic effects
due to their speed so you won't know as
long as is less than the speed of light
everything will look exactly the same
but when you make a long trip and here's
another thing how far can we explore our
universe suppose a star is 200 light
years away that means even if you travel
at the speed of light it's going to take
you 200 years to go into 200 years to
come back and brag about it right can
you do it if your lifetime is only a
hundred years the answer is you can
because if you go fast enough you stop
aging you can go you can go to the
planet you can turn around and come back
and you could have aged only two days
but you won't have anybody to brag to
because everybody is gone there 400
years old but you can do it so there is
no limit it's very interesting the speed
of light imposes a limit on how fast we
can travel so it looks like in a hundred
years you can go only a hundred light
years and that's wrong because as you
travel you slow down your clock your own
biological clock that's the other thing
if you worried about the biological
clock and you're waiting for mr. right
or mr. right now mr. mrs. right whatever
it is get on a rocket ship
and tell them to call you when somebody
reasonable comes along